west africa's regional alliance ecuas
meeting in the ghanaian capital accra
the issue being discussed what if any
new sanctions should be imposed on mali
because of delays to its democratic
transition ecowas chairman and president
of ghana made his view clear in his
opening statement
it is my expectation
that we will take the appropriate
decisions that will advance the future
of mali
and our community
national regional and international
stakeholders
are all awaiting the result of our
meeting
the leaders announced a raft of new
sanctions on mali including border
closures suspending financial
transactions and withdrawing their
ambassadors the measures are in response
to mali's military leaders saying they
plan to stay in power for four more
years instead of holding elections next
month
as much as we are aware of the
complexity of the situation in this
country we are convinced that all
political economic and social reforms
aimed at rebuilding of mali could only
be carried out by democratically elected
authorities
when junta leader colonel assimi guerta
was sworn in last july following two
military coups in less than a year he
sought to unite malians and promised
presidential elections would be held
this year but then two weeks ago a
conference charged with recommending an
election timetable said the polls should
be delayed by between six months and
five years
ecowas has already imposed sanctions on
malian officials so will a new round
make any difference some analysts are
skeptical so i would have thought that
requires leaders would have used a much
more
nuanced engaged approach
with the malian leaders i i'm not too
sure
and particularly
conveys that the sanctions regime
is going to be very successful
mali's leaders say elections can't be
held next month because of security
concerns they also want time to draft a
new constitution and put it before
voters in a referendum ekwa says the
delays are unacceptable it's activated
its standby force and says it will be
ready for any eventuality
victoria gatenby al jazeera